oh my
so Adam Schiff now admits he should have
been much more clear about how he
unleashed the impeachment circus know
when a politician says they should be
much more clear they mean I wish you
hadn't caught me lying to your face I
should have been much more clear and I
said so the minute was brought to my
attention that I was referring to the
fact that when the whistleblower filed
the complaint we had not heard from the
whistleblower we wanted to bring the
whistleblower in at that time but I
should have been much more clear about
that you know instead of trying to be
clear it might just save time if you
just decided to be honest otherwise it's
like hunter Biden saying that although
he did nothing wrong he's not gonna do
it anymore
hunter says he's no longer gonna work
for China cuz we found out you know he
was working for China so shift champions
transparency all the while saying the
whistleblower might not testify because
it's a safety concern he maintains
because we all know CIA agents can't
protect themselves against non-existent
threats or that our government can
protect him from your Aunt Sally our
primary interest right now is making
sure that that person is protected
indeed now there's more than one
whistleblower that they are protected
and given that we already have the call
record we don't need the whistleblower
who wasn't on the call to tell us what
took place during the call we have the
best evidence of that we want to make
sure that we uncover the full details
about the conditionality of either the
military aid or that meeting with
ukrainian President it may not be
necessary to take steps that might
reveal the whistleblowers identity to do
that not necessary so much for
transparency but like everything the
Dems haven't thought this through
so not only go to impeach Trump you're
gonna do it in secret in the dark
reversing an election based on hearsay
for some anonymous guy you will never
ever see who has ties to Democrats this
is what the Dems stand for and it might
not sit well with half of America and
it's just another WiDi tool I shift nose
with each passing day how absurd this
story looks so better to hide it from
you
so the Dems must now rely on a simply
moronic retort if you want to know why
we're impeaching the president we're
just gonna have to impeach him to find
out it's garbage they
we know it good news you know it too so
you know do you want to see Tom salute
did an amazing impression of Adam Schiff
reading nursery rhymes yeah let's it
let's do it okay and now Adam Schiff
reads nursery rhymes Humpty Dumpty sat
on a wall mr. Dumpty and his fondness
for walls represent support of our
corrupt president Humpty Dumpty had a
great fall
clearly a reference to the fall of our
democracy under President Trump that
creeped the hell out of me almost as
much as the real Adam Schiff judge well
yeah it looks like Adams but you know
the truth is that you know why they so
worried about this whistleblower that's
cracksmen I didn't know Obama fire the
whistleblower and fast and furious I
mean oh yeah I'm telling you you did
that was you know shipwide if the guy
used to try cases don't say you misspoke
you lied you lied you waited a month you
created a narrative you got lawyers
started tweeting the tea it all up
you're a liar that's the end of it yeah
what about it
the thing is we protected Sammy the bull
Gravano he killed 19 people and you
write it out John Gotti yeah I think the
whistleblower could be fairly fairly
secure it's obvious that Adam Schiff
wants the to protect himself
he's the secrecy that he he craves is
secrecy for himself you know and he
should I don't want to tell you how to
do the GG show but next time have him
call to get the naked pictures of Trump
I think he would crushed that impression
he did a very good job and Adam Schiff
looks good his face looks nice really
nice-looking he looks like he's trying
to silence the whistleblower and Adam
Schiff I mean what's the point now
you're gonna have a secret agent in the
CIA come out and anonymously tea up a
secret impeachment in dark behind
America's back that's what's going on
here because they don't want the
American people to see what they're
doing and they don't want Republicans to
ask why were you guys in coats with each
other you and Adams shifts people why'd
you lie on the forum when you said you
had no contact with Congress and great
peace and
the Washington Examiner Dana meeting
again breaking news alert puts out very
interesting things about how this whole
thing happened Adam Schiff hired away to
national security council officials from
the Trump White House right before the
guy blew the whistle so he steals away
to Obama Clinton people for the NSC then
write the next month all of a sudden the
whistleblower comes to contact the
committee that he just hired these guys
from and then the whistle is blown those
are the kind of questions he doesn't
want to have answered by Republicans you
know Danny we don't people say oh it's a
it's a coup but it doesn't look good if
you're doing this behind the scenes and
in the dark it started to hear that so
they were on recess last week and a lot
of them did their town hall meetings and
you saw a few Democrats today and I
think there's only like seven who are
not on board for impeachment but there
were more that came back from those town
halls saying you know I think that we
should have the vote we should make sure
that it's fair we should want them to
have that and you start to see that
their tone has changed a little bit on
that mm-hmm
you went what let's say I go to that
Trump tweet about hunter Biden and
discuss hunters next to move oh this is
this isn't the one I wanted you're fired
whoever this is that it was the tweet
about hunter ton when they find that can
I just say that I urge the president not
to cooperate he's cooperating much too
much as it is yeah unless and until
there is a hearing or a vote rather on
the impeachment inquiry
there should be no cooperation by the
White House it was a vote for Nixon in
74 a vote for Clinton in 98 there should
be a vote for President Trump right now
in 19 the fact that they are proceeding
without a vote in secret makes this a
Star Chamber
it is absolutely intolerable the
president should just stiff on so you're
saying you shouldn't have released a
transcript no the transcript is fine
what do you do is you no witnesses
nobody in the cabinet I don't understand
why this a trickle out now of certain
witnesses that are let's I lift his name
some does yeah on Thursday I mean why
why why cooperate at all if they don't
believe in their own
damn impeachment enough to have a vote
on the inquiry then then then the hell
with them that's what I don't know if
you guys saw but I think Rasheeda Talib
says that she's discussing with other
Democrats about imprisoning white house
officials shall refused to go up to this
secret hearing that they're having
that's just not how any of this works
because she got all ginned up and she
was trying she was drunk that's not what
that means yeah drinking a lot of gin
yeah yeah that's quite a smear there was
a tweet for 100 by anyway Trump said he
said wow hunter Biden is being forced to
leave a Chinese company now watch the
fake news wrap their greasy and very
protective arms around him only softball
questions of him please rise okay what
is Hunter being treated fairly or
unfairly hunter is being treated as
though he is a patrician above us all
you know people worry about a double
standard than in the justice system if I
were to try this case against Hunter
Biden the first thing I do would be to
put up this statement of his father and
then do a timeline of when his father
was appointed the point man for energy
in Ukraine and China and this guy who's
got all kinds of problems with his own
personal demons I understand we're not
supposed to talk about those thrown out
of the navy of a dirty dirty urn I mean
cocaine I mean the guy and now the guys
getting a 1.5 billion dollars from the
Chinese they don't give you anything it
was because he used his father's
position that's corrections that them
coming out and saying that he's no
longer going to do it right it shouldn't
have done it while his father was vice
president well not only that money back
but Joe Biden also last week had said
that he would have a policy that if he
becomes president he would have nobody
and his family would work in the White
House well does that is that true for
his vice president yeah because that
would be the actual parallel the other
thing is for tomorrow night when the
bate happens basically by Deena said
don't do it don't ever come towards me
suit but he has insured because hundred
Biden's doing this interview tomorrow
right it'll be the first question you
probably get applause for his response
and then unless any of those other
twenty twenty Democrats come after him
that would be the first headline and
it'll be Biden taking on Trump on
impeachment where he probably should
have been all along and they have to get
on the same page hunter says I talked to
my father my father said I never talked
to him so which one is it y'all I mean
either ignorant or you're corrupt I
don't know which one's more dangerous I
think we I think hunter has got a name
for his book though from hunter to
hunted yes my life is a hard partying
grifter